what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
ed and liz's breakup on 90 day fiance
i'm actually pretty new to the 90 day
fiance scene so this is
brand new to me um this is gonna be my
like honest reaction before i start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel i'm trying to hit 20 000
subscribers as you guys
know um and don't forget to ring that
notification bell that way you're gonna
be notified of my daily
videos okay now
we are going to start with ed
and liz we see you guys are sitting
not together today what's going on um we
broke up
you broke up yeah we broke up a month
ago
today okay well
the last time that we saw you because
she's so out of his league
i do not know what's going on you were
making plans
to move in together what happened
um ed loves to rush
our relationship when we finally became
a couple
the next week i was meeting his daughter
the next week i was meeting his sister
his brother i was thrown in
multiple situations i was not prepared
for
it took me months to introduce him to
my grandparents months for that to
happen
to break up two weeks later
dang
i can tell i've heard that ed can be
clingy oh this is
emotional for you to talk about right
now what are you feeling
i just would have never taken those
steps
if i knew that this was going to be the
outcome because i was not expecting this
to be the outcome
i was expecting to
be with each other i never thought he
would not be a part of my life
wow i thought he was gonna be the one oh
she seems so hurt
so now i'm here on the single life
single
it is the reason that you two are no
longer a couple because you were taking
the relationship too fast
um
well he looks like he's trying to cry
how long did they date
um 90 days right
we moved way too fast like she didn't
have a chance our relationship didn't
have a chance
so everything she said is true
she told me um i don't want to move too
fast and and
i want to keep my friends and i just
skipped right over that i
was so excited for the first time in
29 years that i had somebody that
was interested in me
and i was so afraid
to like anyone to like liz
because i would get rejected and the
minute
she said i see you as boyfriend material
i stopped listening i didn't listen to
one word she said
and i was like i'm gonna i'm gonna make
her my girlfriend i'm gonna make
her world amazing i'm gonna do
everything i can
okay so how did it end i gotta know
to give her what i thought she deserved
she never had
and i [ __ ] it up oh i [ __ ] it up
at one point i felt like if i didn't go
at his pace i was gonna lose him
he wouldn't want me anymore so i would
cave in and go at his speed
what made you think that he wouldn't
want you anymore if you didn't go at his
speed
he would tell me all the time that it
wouldn't work out between us
and it scared me that i would lose him
so i caved
i didn't want to lose him and i still
lost him
dang
the only she seems really hurt
oh my gosh i want to give her a
it's hug up ed did you tell her that
liz i never i mean you knocked me off my
world man
well he shut me out
i don't want to get hurt i got hurt
you hurt me you
just completely left me and you promised
me you wouldn't leave
me this month has been
oh sis i've been there oh my god i've
been there
oh this hurts my soul
she's so out of his league too oh my god
you blocked me and went to vegas
and ranted about your sugar babies oh my
god
wow oh my god what a scumbag
i'm so confused right now are you saying
that
ed was hanging out with other women
i didn't expect to be dumped and then
him be out in vegas living the life
oh
oh wow how soon after
you guys broke up did you know he was
hanging out in vegas
like two days oh oh
two days damn bro wow
liz you deserve better couldn't even
wait three days ed
[Music]
[Music]
dang i don't know what happened that was
a short clip
i kind of see the draw of 90 day fiance
like that was pretty entertaining
i was entertained but let me know in the
comments if you like this
this type of reaction oh my god
no